this is so crazy oh I really really love
this got to document this moment this is
my dream sandwich this is absolutely
worth coming to this is an ode to
Portland I'm in Portland one of my
favorite cities on the west coast and
I'm here with my lovely friend Morgan
who's gonna show me all her favorite
local bites around the city let's go
[Music]
and now you know where we are we're at
voodoo donuts we've got to try out these
tricked-out Donuts that they've got
they're all over Instagram it's like
such a poor Luther it's just funky and
something you have to try at least one
yeah let's try it though I'm tres
Shannon and I'm cat daddy voodoo
doughnut in Portland Oregon we started
out in 2003 with our first crazy Donuts
that we did we did the voodoo doll we
did the OTB
we've been having fun with those Donuts
ever since we'll start with making some
bacon maple bars the bacon maple bar is
a raised donut in the shape of a bar and
it's dipped in maple and then lovingly
adorned with a strip of bacon cut in
half and placed at a 45-degree angle
where the meat greets the sweet it's
delicious we've got the old dirty
bastard which is the one we're making
now which is a chocolate frosting base
dipped in crushed Oreos and then topped
with drizzled peanut butter
we had a worker it was kind of into the
wu-tang clan at some point and it's a
delicious doughnut very popular and the
lesser will do is that we do dump we're
gonna fill them with raspberry filling
and then we dip them in chocolate and
then we'll pipe on all the frostings on
it and then the last step a pretzel
steak the voodoo doughnut is almost the
first donut we invented completely on
our own we put the eyes the mouth and a
swirl on the donut simply because we're
not good artists our artists now have
really taken it over the top there's
several different colors and it's just
been kind of a fun little thing to do
with a simple chocolate doughnut with
raspberry filling with a pretzel stick
adorned in there for the booty pan we're
just so humbled and thrilled that people
want to come down and have a wonderful
doughnut and hoody done it oh my god so
you've got the maple bacon of course you
have the cereal ones you've got Oreo
with some peanut butter on there this
one is obviously a classic gotta get
this video I'm a classic donut kind of
girl and these are you can branch out
some to branch out I'm gonna go for the
ol Dirty Bastard
I want to go for the maple bacon great
oh let's try these out okay I feel like
usually with maple bacon you have like a
little bacon fits it's all crumbled up
the business a full-on piece of bacon
don't uh cheers Wow it's super sweet got
to do a donut selfie that's what you do
when you come to boo do their super
fluffy the flavors are so over-the-top
I kind of want to try the voodoo doll we
got to document this moment definitely
my favorite this feels like the most
classic one shape is so fun so funky
this one you have to try when you come
to video I'm so glad we tried this this
is such a staple I think we probably
need to take these to go yeah we
definitely should okay so where are we
now so we got to hit up pals because
it's the musty in Portland great I've
heard that this is like one of the
coolest bookstores in the country it's a
great place to visit when you're here
awesome let's check it out
[Music]
so we're at lardo this is my pick for
the best sandwiches and Portland's and
we're gonna try the porchetta and we got
to get the fries so I love pork so much
and I also love fries
[Music]
my name is Rick Dan Corelli and we are
at lardo on Hawthorne in Portland Oregon
Florida was a sandwich shop that started
in 2012 it started as just a handful of
sandwiches out of a food cart the
porchetta sandwich was one of the first
sandwiches on the cart we bring in whole
hog middle and I used to have to leave
this thing at on display back in the day
that's kind of what got a lot of people
excited about what was going on the idea
that somebody would take this massive
piece of meat and turn it into a
sandwich was crazy and fun classic
porchetta is done with the loin in the
belly in its entirety and the loin gets
wrapped in the belly
you know the belly sort of protects all
that lean meat and adds fat to it it's
kind of cut it up so that it fits on the
sandwich a little better this is a
ciabatta
there's sort of a light crunchiness to
the outside of it that's just perfect
for these types of sandwiches and then
we build the sandwich with a house-made
gremolata some arugula a little Parmesan
cheese and a caper mayonnaise it's a
great example of how we approach a
sandwich here
Wow
thank you it's one of the most popular
sandwiches here it looks so indulgent
and decadent it's like my dreams and
it's perfect cheat day cheap things
exactly exactly
it's so good hmm nice and crispy
you know porchetta is usually pretty
fatty but it doesn't taste fatty it's
thin enough that it's crispy and then
you have it the seasoning also then
there's also creaminess from the a oh
yeah the only is pretty perfect addition
yeah and some like pepperiness from the
arugula it's a really incredible it's
healthy because you have green this
looks like a salad thin wedge I also got
to get in these fries well they're
perfectly crispy on the outside and then
on the inside they still have that soft
edge in there which is like the perfect
combination yeah this sandwich is a
winner you've got to come here Cheers
[Music]
so we're at the international Rose test
Garden and it's one of my favorite
places to bring people in Portland
Portland Saburo City right it is I've
never seen so many roses in one spot my
mom's a gardener and I grew up
surrounded by plants and it's just like
nothing makes me happier it's beautiful
look at this color they're so vibrant
and they name them all kinds of
different names after people and just
funny things I'm so glad you are able to
come and see the Rose Garden here I mean
it's truly an ode to the city so let's
go check out some roses on the way out
to Beast great perfect Africa hi I'm
Naomi Pomeroy
and we're at beast restaurant in
Portland Oregon beast is a small
intimate 26 seat restaurant we do a pre
feed menu so it's a set course six menu
and the menu changes completely every
two weeks as you can see from the space
it's tiny and in order to really make it
work financially we needed to make sure
that everyone would sit down at the same
time and eat the same thing because we
just opened with me and my sous chef and
then over time we've evolved and have a
bigger team working back here so the
kitchen is open you can see everything
that we're doing and we just wanted to
create something that was really
delicious food that focuses on the
things that we can find locally around
here we're really looking to have them
feel like they're coming to dine
basically in our home I'm so excited
we're here at beast this is one of the
most exclusive restaurant experiences in
the city the restaurant itself is so
beautiful there's all these incredible
flowers everywhere this is gonna be
really good
i'm luciene poets and i'm the chef de
cuisine here at beast restaurant in
Portland so the first course is a
heirloom tomato and fromage blanc tart
so we do is we make kind of a basic pie
dough or peppers egg using a little bit
of rye flour for our crust with that
we've got a little salad of some really
awesome heirloom purple cabbage some
napa cabbage lemon juice and really nice
olive oil on that and then some lightly
roasted heirloom tomatoes kind of set
that all into a tart a couple different
varieties of basil this one is a lemon
basil and then this is a opal basil and
then this black olive caramel so it's
basically equal parts sugar and Nicoise
olives and then blend them together
really simple and straightforward
you know the other thing about this
restaurant which is so cool is that we
actually get to see the makings of food
which feels really special you know
usually it's like hidden away and you
just surprise your toes and this is so
cool that you actually get to be part of
cooking experience this caramel looks
insane it's like a rainbow okay let's
see oh my gosh it's so good it's like a
sweet olive oh my gosh the crust is so
flaky dude so fresh it's like the sweet
and savory combination together and the
layers of the tart are amazing it feels
like very vibrant I'm just like the
right amount of acid I do feel like I
could eat an entire time that is true I
literally want to carry the olive
caramel around with me in my purse and
like a little spray bottle just such sir
main course at Beast this week and next
we have duck breasts coming from
California and seasoned with juniper and
some thyme we're just gonna roast in a
pan with a little bit of butter and at
that point we're just gonna go into the
oven for a couple minutes pretty - a
couple preparations of some summer
squash with that one is just kind of
roasted the other is just sliced really
thinly and cured with some sugar and
salt also with that we've got some
really awesome Oregon chanterelle
mushrooms a kind of classic piece - this
one's gonna be made with dandelion
greens or some bitterness on the dish
some parsley a little bit of lemon zest
garlic and lots of olive oil and then we
have some Oregon blackberries that we've
done a play on a sauce Cumberland with
like to set the duck with the skin out
facing the guest so you can see all the
hard work that went into it last step is
just finishing it with the sauce using
veal bone lamb bones and duck bones red
wine and blackberry puree and just a
little bit of Dijon mustard
oh this is so gorgeous duck is my number
one favorite thing if there is duck them
I knew I had to get it so you're going
to enjoy this
I love it that's intended it's so tender
in this sauce oh my gosh it's really
delicate I actually feel my mouth water
talking while you're eating it
this dish is basically the perfect
representation of Portland absolutely I
mean when I think of Portland and Oregon
I think of nature and this feels very
much from the bounty of this incredible
exactly Portland on a plate Portland on
a plate oh so desert wrapping up our
menu it's a beautiful kind of light cake
that's been soaked in a corn infused
milk so kind of like a tres leches cake
so our dessert plate starts with that
blueberry and tamarind sauce have our
cake here got here's a little bit of a
corn custard or a corn curd a little bit
more of that blueberry sauce we've got
here is actually some sliced blueberries
as well this is just a little bit of
corn it's been roasted in a pan with a
little bit of butter some sugar and some
salt so light streusel crumb and then a
sorbet that's made with buttermilk lime
and more blueberry oh my gosh
I think you oh wow okay what do you
think of corn cake what do you expect
that this is gonna taste like like
cornbread I mean it looks like tres
leches cake back losing the colors are
just beautiful they work so well I'm in
very complementary here mmm it's so good
it's so light and airy and just the
right amount of sweetness it's not
overpowering but you really do taste the
corn it feels like really sweet summer
corn again it's seasonal we have the
fresh blueberries the blueberries are in
the sorbet I love how they use what's in
season and what's local right now it's
like a symphony of flavors and textures
coming together you want to buy too
thick
it's good right that's so true
this is incredible so good like can we
take you home of this meal has exceeded
all expectations it is really it's been
a highlight of my career it's really
good thank you beast it's such a
beautiful restaurant the food is so
exquisite there's so much care that has
gone into this
this is absolutely worth coming to I had
so many awesome experiences to choose
from in Portland and now I get to choose
how to pay for them with payant planet
from American Express I'm so glad you
had fun
[Music]
you